[Musica]
davide scusate stavo cercando di fare
qualcosa per la voce è quella che
purtroppo allora il tempo il tempo dello
sport un aspetto essenziale
ecco qui un esempio magari mi sposto che
ingombro
procedi lascia trascorrere il tempo sei
secondi ancora per l'azione della felice
8 al termine della partita premierà il
tiro da tre allo scadere prende il ferro
4 secondo in tre secondi due secondi con
totti per forti libero sotto teresa del
vecchio maestro in sede
bene
altrimenti
da fitch
qualcuno di voi per caso sa che partita
è bene non me l'aspettavo pensavo di
dover mettere invece immagini di rugby
visto la terra comunque si è una delle
partite più famose della storia del
basket italiano alla finale scudetto
1989 tra livorno e milano più
precisamente la gara 5 l'ultima decisiva
gara 5
quello che avete visto sono proprio gli
ultimi secondi milano avanti di un punto
sbaglia un tiro c'è la possibilità per
livorno di provare a correre in
contropiede e di prendere un tiro cosa
che fa con andrea forti che tira sulla
sirena
allo scadere da lì si entra in un mondo
surreale per mezz'ora almeno insomma da
una parte milano nello spogliatoio
festeggia lo scudetto in campo livorno
coi tifosi festeggia lo scudetto
i giornalisti confusi segue i fotografi
si guardano intorno ai vecchi
fotografiamo nel dubbio fotografano
tutti così sicuro la squadra che ha
vinto l'ha fotografata finalmente una
mezz'ora dopo qualcuno riesce a entrare
nello spogliatoio dove si erano ritirati
gli arbitri ed esce con la notizia il
canestro non è buono e arrivato dopo lo
scadere lo scudetto di milano qualche
giorno dopo alla domenica sportiva
cercano di dare una risposta un minimo
più scientifica diciamo per cui
basandosi sulle immagini televisive
analizzano i frame non sto a spiegarvi
frame perché non li ho capiti comunque
sono frazioni di secondo dell'immagine e
viene fuori che effettivamente il
canestro è arrivato dopo lo scadere di
un decimo un decimo abbondante
ovviamente io lo racconto sereno perché
giocava milano fosse stato a livorno
probabilmente lo racconta lei con altri
toni
detto questo e per fare il giusto per
fare un esempio che a volte nello sport
un secondo un decimo di secondo
possono decidere una partita possono
decidere una stagione
possono decidere a volte veramente anche
una carriera intera
però ci sono anche tanti altri tipi di
tempo per esempio uno più temuto in
assoluto dagli atleti sono i tempi di
recupero da un infortunio dove oltre
alla fatica al dolore ea quel brutto
strisciante pensiero che forse non
tornerai più quello di prima
c'è un altro aspetto che forse mai
quello che pesava di più è quello in cui
tu sei da solo se non secoli tuoi
compagni non vivi la vita quotidiana
della squadra non va in trasferta non ti
alleni non giochi non partecipi e questa
una sensazione per chi fa sport di
squadra abbastanza spiacevole
poi c'è un altro tipo di tempo ancora
che forse potrei chiamare tempo dilatato
io l'ho accusavo ai massime e
dell'attesa della partita dell'evento
soprattutto quelle importanti tutti
svegli la mattina e davanti non so 10
ore e ti sembrano cento l'orologio
continuamente le lancette immobili
sembra 6 isterico nessuno ti può stare
vicino momenti di solitudine
poi pranzi provi a fare a dormire un po
non sempre ci riesce
poi arriva l'ora di andare al campo
mediamente un'oretta e mezza un'ora e
mezza prima della partita lì anche se
non sembra possibile
il tempo rallenta ancora sale la
tensione tu cerchi di ingannarla con
piccoli rituali piccole scaramanzie che
in qualche modo pensi ti possono far
sentire un po più sicuro approcciare
meglio la partita
poi finalmente si gioca si alza la palla
2 e banda entra in un mondo diverso
tutto è velocissimo caotico quasi
frenetico non hai più tempo per pensare
poi solo fare una cosa affidarti i tuoi
istinti però questi non sono istinti
innati sono istinti che in qualche modo
tu hai dovuto costruire e l'unico modo
che ha per costruire questi istinti e
lavorare in palestra e tutto il lavoro
che c'è a monte in primis le ore che
ogni giocatore passa in palestra per
lavorare sul suo corpo sul suo gioco per
affinare i suoi pregi per limare i suoi
difetti per perfezionare il suo gioco
un movimento la meccanica di un gesto
che ti permette di farlo sotto pressione
quando non hai tempo per pensare che ti
permette di renderlo il più possibile
naturale quasi automatico appunto
perché per poter prendere delle
decisioni veloci preferibilmente giuste
sotto pressione tutto questo lavoro è
decisivo
e tutto questo a tutto questo lavoro ti
permette a volte purtroppo sola volte di
sperimentare un altro tipo di tempo
non so come chiamarlo tempo sospeso
forse ai miei tempi lo chiamavano trance
agonistica
adesso quelli che che parlano bene lo
definiscono stato di flow stato di
flusso ed è una sensazione unica
ti senti al centro di tutto intorno a te
sembra che tutto rallenti che sai
perfettamente quello che sta per
succedere
doveva il pallone doveva un avversario
quello che fa il compagno io non so mai
stato capace di ricrearlo sarebbe troppo
facile ogni volta però a volte davvero
così succede ed è veramente una
sensazione meravigliosa
però il lavoro che ogni giocatore mette
per diventare migliore è solo una parte
dell'equazione perché ovviamente il
basket è uno sport di squadra come il
rugby e allora c'è bisogno di cercare di
rendere un gruppo un insieme di persone
che sono eterogenee per provenienza per
caratteristiche tecniche per
caratteristiche umane e caratteriali
cercare di renderle un gruppo un gruppo
omogeneo un gruppo unico
un gruppo che in qualche modo parla lo
stesso linguaggio tecnico e che sa cosa
aspettarsi uno dall'altro e anche qui
l'unico modo per farlo è passare del
tempo in palestra tutti insieme
lavorando
gregg popovich allenatore san antonio
spurs squadra professionistica americana
con cui ha vinto cinque titoli negli
ultimi anni è considerato uno dei più
grandi allenatori di basket di sempre
sostiene che il segreto del loro
prolungato successo è solo uno ogni anno
ricominciare da capo
dalle basi dalle fondamenta non importa
quanti giocatori magari c'erano già
l'anno prima quanto poco sia cambiata la
squadra quanti giocatori siano lì da
dieci anni e queste cose le abbiamo
fatte
centinaia di volte non importa è l'unico
modo non puoi prendere scorciatoie non
puoi saltare dei passaggi perché ti devi
dare il tempo di sbagliare e di
correggere gli errori deve avere la
pazienza di sbagliare e di correggere
gli errori
solo questo è il modo per riuscire avere
in qualche modo successo solo questo è
il modo di poter essere in qualche modo
pronto quando davvero la tensione sarà
alta per sottolineare questo aspetto per
ricordarlo gregg popovich ha fatto
attaccare questo
cartello nello spogliatoio dove c'è una
frase una frase di jacob ris via
coprisse un era un sociologo americano
di origine danese di metà 800 primi 900
e l'ha fatta a tradurre nella lingua di
ognuno dei giocatori presenti nella
squadra per esempio quando io ho
visitato lo spogliatoio ce n'era una in
italiano in portoghese un francese uno
spagnolo e ovviamente in inglese per i
giocatori americani
il titolo che potremo dare a questa
frase credo sia il credo del
tagliapietre o se volete in inglese
pound in the rock e più o meno
recita così quando niente sembra aiutare
io vado a vedere il lavoro di un
tagliapietra che colpisce centinaia di
volte la roccia senza che si veda una
crepa poi alla 101esima la roccia si
apre in due ma io so che non è stato
quell ultimo colpo sono stati 100
precedenti ecco al di là cat
trovo che sia una bella frase che forse
dovremmo tenere a mente
ogni tanto nella vita quando davvero
niente sembra funzionare
mi ricordo una parola una bella parola
perseveranza una virtù che anche questa
forse dovremmo tenere più presente
praticare di più nella nostra vita
perché davvero può aiutare
tornando a quella partita
io all'epoca avevo 21 anni e pensavo più
o meno inconsciamente chissà quante
altre volte mi capiterà di giocare
partite del genere anche perché la
sensazione è brutta non era e ovviamente
immaginate 0
ok ho giocato altre finali magari
importanti uguali ma finale il furetto 0
in più l'atleta da una carriera
relativamente breve per ovvi motivi un
giorno ti svegli il tuo corpo ti dice
amico
basta non ce la facciamo più in qualche
modo insomma gli sportivi sono merce
deperibile e quando ho smesso di giocare
mi sono reso conto che forse non ero
riuscito a vivere tutti i momenti come
avrei voluto
che insomma per tornare al tema di oggi
quei 40 minuti in più oggi
adesso mi piacerebbe riuscire a
prenderli per apprezzare per apprezzare
di più tutto anche i momenti di tensione
anche quelli di stress anche la fatica
che può essere anche terapeutica in
tante situazioni
insomma quello che sto cercando di dire
che vinciate o che perdiate godetevi
l'attimo più che potete
grazie
[Applauso]
beh
red